hey youtubers is Charlie so this week on
Gotham vigilantes are popping up
everywhere and it is raining dead bodies
I don't know about you guys but Selina
Kyle and Gordon are my new favorite
pairing at least next to awesome Alton
Gordon they also just cast Harvey Dent
on the show it's Nicolas de Gaston no
idea when he's gonna show up but they're
filming episode nine right now
so probably sometime after that so let's
start with top five moments then I'll do
my review and then I have some arrow
flash news careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet I'll
wait just a sec okay ready number five
meet Sal Maroni this is the character
that Eric Roberts played on The Dark
Knight
so based on the timeline we can guess
he's only gonna be getting worse from
here on out if he's still around
whenever Bruce Wayne eventually turns
into Batman
this season on Gotham he's being played
by David Zaius from Dexter so it is fun
watching him be evil after he was a cop
on that show
he feels like an actor who just fits
into this comic book Dick Tracy type
world really well it's pretty clear that
they're setting up for a big
confrontation between him and Falcone I
did love the Emperor's New Clothes
reference in the episode he said the
emperor has no clothes but you get the
idea he's just calling Falcone out as a
fool who can't see what's going on
around him or at least Maroni believes
that I think Falcone is pretty shrewd so
I don't think that fish Mooney or any of
the other big mobster characters are
gonna be able to dump him in the bay I
am kind of wondering if Falcone is gonna
start working with Jim Gordon like the
penguin is like some of the big
criminals on the show will help Gordon
to take down other criminals number four
Bruce and Alfred finally get to have a
little bit of fun I was glad that they
finally let the characters loosen up a
little bit yes Bruce Wayne is a dark
character but that does not mean he
can't have fun he is still a little kid
despite the fact that we haven't seen
him interact with other little kids I'm
really hoping we get some Catwoman
Bruce scenes pretty soon the fencing was
a lot of fun in the comics you know
Batman mostly does a lot of punching but
he does sword fight whenever he's
fighting villains that primarily use
swords like Raja ghoul really all the
Bruce scenes were not subtle at all they
just want us to watch Bruce stuck on the
idea of protecting Gotham without you
yourself turning into a criminal in the
process if it seems like they're beating
us over the head with you know Bruce
Wayne and becoming Batman it's just
because it's so early in the season they
just need to
these storylines but I'm really hoping
to see later this season is an episode
where Bruce actually goes out and tries
to help someone like if you see someone
in trouble while they're out in public
or see him try to deal with a bully
somehow or deal with like a little kid
problem in a Batman type way the
detective line was also a really great
reference to Batman being the world's
greatest detective
number three penguin on the rise I think
the speed with which they brought him
back into the city tells you just how
important his character is to season one
I did like to think even the very
penguin looking suit at the end of the
episode it's all just set up for him and
Gordon teaming up to deal with the storm
brewing on that map that he had in
episode 2 it doesn't really address the
Arkham situation that much that's also
gonna be a big part of this map right
here in the middle pretty soon
interesting sidenote in the comics
Maroni actually helped fund Hugo Strange
experiments at Arkham Asylum on the
orders of Falcone I don't know if the
show's gonna go in that direction but
he'll estranged will be a part of the
Arkham storyline this season we just
haven't seen him yet
just think of Oswalt as being like the
evil medium that's gonna help him see
all these other evil spirits and deal
with them the realities are being that
once Gordon deals with all these bigger
people it will pave the way for Oswalt
to take some of their power
number two Catwoman and Gordon are on
the case definitely my favorite pairing
the episode Selina Kyle montages have
been the most fun so far did you notice
how they're letting her give people the
Batman slip like she'll just appear and
disappear as she pleases their field
trip was just a continuation of the
Wayne mystery I know based on the shiny
shoes and the way that they're
positioning people in the story there
are a lot of theories about maybe the
penguin being the person that murdered
them it's true in the comics Joe Chill
is the killer but the show might be
doing something different
it could just be merging Joe Chill with
the penguin character it's just that in
the comics Joe Chill isn't like a shiny
shoe type person and they're trying to
make the person on this show that killed
them seem like somewhat of means they're
someone with a sense of style like
someone who wears really nice suits it
might just be crazy enough to kill the
richest people in Gotham plus I do like
the implication that the penguin will
help Gordon put all these huge villains
behind bars but they ain't Gordon's
gonna realize that his biggest ally is
also the person behind this big huge
season one murder mystery and my number
one moment
vigilantes are on the rise and more
coming the phrase more are coming is
probably going to end up on a poster
before the end of the season it's all
foreshadowing for future people they're
gonna be bringing on the show like
they're gonna be more vigilantes mostly
violent ones I mean there are a lot of
Batman vigilantes most of them are
pretty crazy the really interesting
thing is that the show also cast Sara
Paxton as Betty Kane in the comic books
she was one of the characters to take on
the mantle of Batgirl I can't find her
on the show's IMDB page anymore but she
was listed several months ago it's
possible that they cut her out of the
pilot or they might not be doing her at
all but they will be bringing on more
actual Batman vigilante characters from
the comics just more people that Bruce
Wayne can point to his inspiration for
better or worse for the most part I
think that Gordon's gonna be the only
positive example for Bruce Wayne at
least in season 1 of the show I mean
he's the protagonist this is really kind
of his show Bruce Wayne's just in it let
me know though what was your favorite
moment and which vigilantes from the
comic books do you want to see the show
bring on there was that whole Barbara
Kean Montoya drug storyline I'm not
really sure what they're doing with
those characters I actually ended up
giving the episode of be overall just
because I felt like the ending
completely threw away that whole Montoya
scene I feel like they were trying to
create a wedge between Gordon and
Barbara but then Barbara just totally
bought Gordon's explanation at the end
they didn't even need to bring the
penguin on I feel like when he showed up
at the door though that was just them
pouring salt in Montoya's wound like the
penguin walks through the door looking
like a million bucks literally about as
far as you can get from being dead so
really the big question is is what the
heck are they trying to do with the
Montoya character because right now she
seems like a total douche it feels like
what they were trying to do was give
some more dimension to the Barbara Kean
character by making her a former drug
addict and a bisexual but they
completely undercut it at the end so I'm
a little confused as to where both of
those female characters are going my
favorite performance in the episode was
of course by Cameron beacon Tova again I
feels like she's one of the few
actresses on the show that understands
that she's in a comic book world like
this is a Dick Tracy environment so you
should just have fun with it some of the
other characters like Ben Mackenzie just
feel like they're taking it a little too
seriously
even though Gordon is a serious
character I would like to see him have a
little bit
more fun I mean this is like a Tim
Burton Batman movie this isn't like
Christopher Nolan where it's like really
really hardcore aside from that my only
other real complaints about the episode
was the Bullock Gordon montage which I
thought was pretty awful
I do like montage storytelling and I
like those characters but I feel like
the music they used was just really out
of place and I just wasn't buying it at
all especially the part with the burrito
at the end so the only big issues I had
with the episode were the montage and
the Montoya scenes but otherwise I
thought it was a really fun episode big
announcements though next up this week
is the flash episode one that's airing
Tuesday tomorrow night I'm gonna try and
get a few more bonus videos up before
then because arrow episode 1 is also on
Wednesday so it's a big week for DC
Comics TV shows I will be doing a
combined Q&A for both the air on the
flash on Thursday but I'm not gonna be
doing a Gotham Q&A I'm just trying to
free up a little bit of time before air
on the flash get here but right now
click here to learn all about my
favorite flash villains of the season
and click here for last week's Gotham
video thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five everybody get ready
a lot of DC TV shows this week
you